[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the deep dive
into Android studio profilers session I
am David Herman I'm Mission Control we
are engineers from the profiler team in
Android studio so before we really got
into it we wanted to give you all an
outline of what to expect in this talk
instead of sort of coming from a high
overview instead we're gonna more
narrowly focus on a few features that we
think can help you get a better handle
on any codebase we're also gonna drop
some tips and tricks along the way we're
going to be profiling a real app Santa
tracker Santa tracker is an app by
Google which allows users to track Santa
as on his course around the world on
Christmas Eve the app also contains
games and a couple of other extras we're
the they released a new app every year
we're gonna be using the one that is
publicly available on github finally I
want to mention two talks about
profilers that were previously given
this year one at Google i/o which did
talk sort of profilers at a higher level
also introducing what was new in Android
studio 3.2 for profilers and another one
at the Android game dove dev summit
about profiling your games that talk
focuses a little bit more on performance
native code related tools things like
that you can find those videos on
YouTube if you're watching this online
we've also included links to those
videos in the video description below if
this is your first time coming of
learning about profilers you're just
curious here's a very quick overview the
studio profilers feature is divided into
four main profilers one for CPU
one from memory one for network and one
for battery there's also an event
profiler that's on the top of that's
always on the top which lets you see
things like user events such as taps
keyboard events screen rotations and
life cycle events so when your fragments
and activity
is start and stop anyway that's enough
talking let's jump into the demo okay
let's start the demo so first with one
click of this button I can launch the
app and start profilers so today we are
using ng Studios 3.4 canarios 3 because
that's the latest of what we have since
they this is a canario release is not a
stable release yet so there might be
some bugs please bare with us if
anything interesting happens today the
app we are using today the Santa tracker
contains only chava apps Java code so
the Java apps will be the focus of
today's talk so as you can see in the
profiler we have four profilers CPU
memory Network and energy you can click
on any of them and to get more detailed
data from that profiler let's jump to
the CPU profiler so here as you can see
in the CPU profiler you can see the CPU
utilization and the thread state they
will be useful if you to tell you when
your app becomes CPU pundit and if you
are examining two related threads one
trick is here you can reorder the
threads any way you want to no further
data information about which part of
your code is executing or how they are
executing you need CPU recordings and
let me get a little bit more space so as
you can see here there are four types of
CPU recordings so let's go to the first
one it's somehow Java methods let's get
a quick recording of this one so in
during this type of CPU recording the
java virtual machine
it's periodically will collect the cost
acts
of all the other Java threads in your
process and then it will present the
stacks in the in this part which we
called it's a recording details of the
recording and after the recording is
done the entire recording is
automatically selected and if you want
to take a closer look there is a button
called zoom to selection so if I click
it it will fill the entire screen and if
you want to just see a sub range of this
recording you can select using your
mouse if you want to select the entire
recording again you can click this small
clock icon here and at some some times
you only want to see a very specific
point then in that case you can do a
single click in this area and if you're
automatically select something here now
let's take a look of the call stacks
here and let's select this range that
might be more interesting so as you can
see the profiler will color the cause
from the NGO flat phone in orange the
method from the Java language in blue
and it will also color any of your code
and library called to green so if you
want to know what language what method
from your code is running you will be
looking for the green stuff so here we
see some green stuff here and here if
you can see this is Uncle method from
the village view class and if it's not
if you see the code base you can easily
see the visit issue is responsible to
draw the clouds that is on this screen
so as well another thing I want you to
talk about about the sampling is you can
do some customization about this
recording type so you click this edit
configuration entry and you can click
this plus sign you are able to create
our
my CPU configuration for this sample
java method recording type you can
change the sampling intervals so as most
sampling technique techniques go the
more frequently you collect some house
the more likely the data will be
representative however that will incur
more overhead so sometimes depending on
your use case you may want to try have
several tries before you find the sweet
spot so as we have seen that the sample
java method is very useful to get a
high-level picture of which part of the
code is running in some other scenarios
if you want to focus on a smaller area
another the second type of the recording
trace java method will be more
interesting so let me collect another
face so in this type of cpu recording
the channel virtual machine is
collecting the data every time when the
execution enters a method or exits a
method so therefore there is a lot of
more data being collected and so for
example if I really want to understand
exactly what methods from my code or
running you I will look for the green
stuff here and you can see it's more
there are a lot of things and you may
want to zoom in so you can use the
tableau ast keys to zoom in so the top
layer will be the zoom in as you can see
the key I'm pressing the S will be zoom
out the T will be moving to the right a
will be moving to the left
so if your came here you probably
already know this if you do mean let's
keep you mean to see what are these
green stuff so here using this a big one
is the one we just saw before
it's the uncle method from the village
view they are responsible for
join the clouds are here this is the
ultra method from the snowflake view
class they are responsible to draw all
these snowflakes that are floating
around and if you look at closely there
are some many very tiny green lines here
so you can further sue me
you can further you mean you can see so
you can see this is the uncle method
from the snowflake class this is also
from Snape from free class so let's so
you may want to see what is that is a
disc Rosco so you right click here and
you can have a menu to jump to the
source code so we you can see here in
this snowflake last snowflake class in
this ondraw method we are doing some
calculation about the velocity about the
angle about the size then we draw circle
then is clear that's every snowflake on
this screen will execute this method
that's why we are seeing so many calls
into this method so as you can see trace
Java method is very useful to verify
whether or not a method has been
executed it's also useful to verify how
often that method is executing another
thing I want to talk about here is about
the four tabs here so the first one is
the call church
so the coach at as we said is
representing all the contacts during the
CPU recording so it's so the things to
the left will let's select the entire
range you can see it so the scenes
contacts shows up the left where happens
first in this recording so the things to
the right will happen later in this
recording in the flame chart it's
similar to the cost cost at but it's
upside down so the
is at the bottom and also identifying
call stacks are aggregated here so it's
very easy to see the total time a method
has been executed
the total is Archie it has exactly the
same data as the frame chart it's just
represented it in a view a different
view so what's nice about this view is
you can sort these methods by the time
so the sale time is the time executing
by this method itself the children is
the time executed by the subroutines
caught by this method and the total
column is the time it's a combination of
the two
bottom-up is looking at the cost tag
upwards to the color basic from the
method to the to another function to
that cottage so here it's very useful if
you expand it you can it's very useful
to see where this a method is caught and
how much time this message has executed
when it is caught by that specific color
and there is a third type of CPU
recording that is somehow native
functions C or C++ functions and let's
do also another short race here and if
you remember I just said this app Santa
tracker
contains Java only code so therefore the
contacts it's to mean the constants
corrected by this type of recording
isn't over it's not very interesting
they're mostly the system cause some
some of them is the android framework
native code so however if your app has
any native components this type of
recording will be very handy there is
another type of CP recording called
trade system talk host but before I go
into the details of that I will hand
back the demo back to Dave
excellent so CPU recordings are very
useful however sometimes there's an
exact function or maybe just a couple of
functions that you know you want to
analyze and it's a little bit imprecise
to record do something your app stopped
recording and then zooming in and search
for it fortunately we provide a very
simple solution for this and I already
added the code in so let's talk about it
so the debug class is actually part of
the Android API and the debug class and
many of its methods have in fact been in
the Android API since the very first
version including these two what the
start method tracing function does is it
asks the system to take a trace save it
with the filename you provide and then
it puts it in a folder somewhere that
you can pull off your device later and
inspect that's really nice but on studio
profilers we've got your back
we'll do all of that work for you so if
you are doing this manually you'd
probably be very careful about the name
that you chose and if you're doing
multiple traces you and maybe choose
unique names so that they didn't
overwrite each other in our case the
name is not gonna show up in studio we
don't really care about it so call it
whatever you want here I'm going to
start doing putting a recording around
this function so what I when I'm curious
about in this case there's an activity
in Santa tracker called the CD quiz and
the CD quiz loads files from the disc
that's usually a really good thing where
you want to know how long it's going to
take and if it's doing anything
suspicious maybe it's not we're gonna
take a look but one thing I do want to
mention is when you call this start
method tracing function it's doing a
trace of your code this is the more
expensive precise detailed one so I'd be
very careful I wouldn't do this around a
large amount of code just to make sure
that it doesn't take longer than you
might expect all right let's actually go
into the CD quiz which is down here see
what happens now before I do this I want
you to keep your eye over here in the
session panel I'm gonna hit play it's
gonna run in and it's automatically
record I didn't have to do anything
that's awesome let me back out so as you
can see here there's nothing new this is
exactly what xiukong was just showing
you before
it's just another trace but you didn't
have to record it yourself I think this
is a good moment to call out the
lifecycle events I talked a little bit
about at the beginning of the talk as
you can see we're doing a load here we
left our previous activity and now we're
into this new activity you can also see
that if you put your mouse over an
activity as of Android studio 3.3 will
also include the fragments that are
active during that time so that may be
useful for you but here we are we're in
this space while we're still loading
before we've actually entered the
activity and there's another really
great feature that I want to show you
here which is this filter button when I
press the filter button it brings up a
search box where I can type into it now
I happen to know that JSON has a
function called read literal so let me
just type that in now one thing you
might notice here is this part of my
call chart dimmed out and all parts of
here are not dim they're still the
normal color so let me zoom in and see
if I could find where that is so there
we go so we could see some instances of
this read literal function basically if
my function is an exact match
it will bold if it's a function that
calls either into that function or is
called out of that function indirectly
the color will be left the same and
otherwise it will dim and it's really
useful to sort of get a good overview of
how much time you're spending in your
code on the function that you care about
versus what you don't have to pay
attention to all of the CPU detail views
support this so the flame chart has the
similar dimming top-down and bottom-up
will strip out those functions that were
dimmed so if you're ever trying to
inspect some sort of method and you're
really narrowing down on it please give
the filter option a try and see if you
can sort of focus on what you're looking
at now the last thing to call attention
to here's all of these traces that we've
done if you mouse over them there's a
Save button here so you can actually
export your traces if you do this you
can give it to a co-worker attach it to
a bug useful things like that if
somebody gives you a trace file or you
are loading one you can just hit the
plus button over here and load it from
file all right
so now I'm going to talk about the last
type of CP recording the cheese system
cause three system cost this feature was
introduced in Android studio 3.2 it
cracks fine-grained system events that's
related to a performance so you can
investigate how your app interacts with
the system resource
so let's correct assistant race so one
thing again I'm using the click to zoom
button here so that it's very easy to
see one thing I want to show you here
the first thing I want to show you is in
this threat state view so if you click
the range i zoom to that selection again
and I work here so here as you can see
you can move with your mouse hover over
you can see this thread state is
runnable become runny then become
runnable become running again so as you
can see we are collecting every CPU
scheduling operation so at this level of
details it's very easy for you to figure
out exactly when your thread becomes
blocked and that could be useful if you
have some threading issues another thing
I want to show using the tree system
cost is to investigate slow UI chunk so
this slow you are rendering also called
jank by some people as you may know that
is the UI Android UI does the work in
two phases the first phase happens in
the main thread it determines what is on
the screen including the layout and the
choice it determines the what by
executing all the UI elements such as
all the
view classes in your app so after the
main threat generates the what they are
passed to the native render thread the
render thread will be figure out how to
draw them then it - how will be passed
to the surface finger system process and
the hardware who is actually performing
the joints so that's that is giving that
background so we can see under the frame
area we have the assessment which
represents the main thread the render
represents the render thread so let me
zoom out a little bit so you can see
here this this is the first phase and
corresponding the second phase will be
here if you are targeting a smooth UI
smooth your animation at 60 frames per
second which is 16 milliseconds roughly
16 milliseconds per frame so the two
phases combined together should be under
16 frames if it's longer than that the
profiler will color that frame to read
so as so you know this is as something
snow so if you zoom out more you can see
a lot of frames I think everyone in
today is red that means everyone is
exceeding the 16 meter second threshold
one reason one factory is we are using
the emulator because the way the
emulator interact with the system you
are going to see more red frames from
then from actual device before today's
talk I have collected another trace
using an actual physical device and I
have exported that trace as a file and
now I want to import that trace to show
you so as Dave said before you can use
this plus sign to import a trace
that's this trace
so because when you trace the system
calls everything the system-wide events
are collected so you need to tell the
provider which process you want to look
at so we want to look at Santa tracker
and as you know the Linux from the
system point of view every process or
every thread that your name can no
longer than 15 characters so that's why
this wine is accurate the Santa tracker
dot debug for some reason system thinks
this is the name so if you select this
one we are going to import this trace
and here you can see from the active
device most of the frames will be
inquiry that indicates they are under 16
milliseconds threshold and some of the
frames are in the red because they are
over that threshold you may wonder how
does the system knows um how does the
profiler knows how long these phases are
taking that is from the tracing points
so Android platform engineers have added
building tracing points into the some of
the critical tasks in Android system so
I mean the example here is if you click
the main thread here these events are
showing from the trace events here so if
i zoom in here you will see this is a
trace event called choreographer to
frame so that's the first phase we just
talked about in the UI rendering in
happens in the main thread if you click
the render thread you can see there is
an event called show frame so that's the
second phase and you can also see there
are other tracing points in the system
there are all building systems so they
are available on any Android phones
because they are building and they are
very useful to get the timing
information for some specific tasks and
actually you can have your own trace
point to you and I'm going to demo that
here so
so here if we go into the top of the app
come back to this view you have the
clouds we have the snowflakes I want to
know exactly how long the my coat is
spent join them so for the cloud I go to
the village view so there should be a
draw method so at the beginning of the
method I add the instrumentation the
trace speaking section you need to
provide a name a string which is the
sections name at the end of the method I
will end this trace event for the
snowflakes it goes to the snowflake view
again it should be a draw method I want
to point out the section name you should
you should pick a name makes sense to
you so you can recognize where you doing
the CPU recording so here we are doing
the snowflake Android dev summit 2018 so
that makes sense for today's demo so now
I have at the menu instrumentation so I
will rebuild as app and we profile it so
while we are waiting for the build you
may want me if I want to know how long
that two methods are taking why don't
you use the trace Java methods that type
of CPU recording huge are talking about
moments ago so I would say trace Java
method is very powerful it's very easy
to use but it has significant overhead
because the java virtual machine is
collecting data every time when the
execution enter of method and every time
when the execution access of method so
if you have a lot of frequent small
method calls that overhead can quickly
add up and become very expensive if you
use the manual instrumentation for
example like the trace using the trace
api you have the full control of one and
we're to collect data so if you use that
wisely the overhead will be much smaller
and as a result the data you click it
will be more accurate
so let's verify the instrumentation we
have so you go to the CPU profiler we
collect a trace of trade system cost and
here you mean you mean we see this event
again karach refer to frame this is from
the main thread that is responsible for
all UI elements and if we keep to me so
you can see this is the frame we just
added village view who is join the
clouds and this is a snowflake view 80s
2018 that's the thing responsible for
showing the snowflakes so this is that
how the use the trace system costs CPU
recording so you may heard a very
similar tool called systrace so actually
my Google coworker common gave a
lightning talk yesterday on the systrace
so it's extremely powerful tool but the
learning curve of the systrace is a
little bit deeper than the NGO studio
profiler so you may choose the truth
that best suits your needs
ok that's for the trace CP recording I
will hand over the demo Bad Fur Day all
right let's leave the CPU profiler
behind and jump over to the memory
profiler first of all I want to draw
everyone's attention to this allocation
tracking pull down some quick history
here in Android studio 3.0 when
targeting Android devices with oo or
newer what we did is we would collect an
allocation a call stack for every single
allocation dier app made we did it
because it would be very convenient to
used to have that history however some
of our users reported that profilers
were slowing their app down after we
investigated it turned out to be this
feature so starting in Android 3.3
hundred thirty three point three we now
give you the option to configure this
let me go ahead and look here so we have
none sampled and full none disables the
feature full enables it and sampled
attempts to collect a subset of the
allocations that sort of gives you a
general look for how your app's memory
behavior is well not actually affecting
your performance as much as a full one
does now that being said whether or not
folk effects your app or not can depend
on the host machine you're running on
whether you're targeting a device or an
emulator or even your code if you're a
code or if your app code has a lot of
small allocations in it like Santa
tracker does it can be slow but I
recommend playing around with the
features I'm gonna go ahead here and
turn full on me alive here so you notice
once I turned on full this allocation
indicator started showing up I want some
interesting things to happen so I'll
just go ahead and rotate the device
rotate it back we'll go back over there
so now let's go ahead and take a look
here so all I need to do at any point is
just drag across and I'm gonna be able
to see all of the allocations and the D
allocations that happened during that
range this could be a really lightweight
way to sort of get a quick look at what
your memory is doing there's an
allocation and de-allocation count so
sometimes you might be able to find
memory leaks even just doing this and
then the other nice thing is maybe if
you have this on and you're doing some
other stuff you can actually go back in
time and select a range and still see
what's going in your memory now I'm
gonna go ahead here and turn it back off
again and you'll notice that the
allocation indicated that it stopped
tracking by doing an empty circle if I
did sampled mode it would put a
half-filled circle now looking at these
objects once I click on it you can see
every single one that's currently
allocated as long as well as the
where it was allocated this is very
useful to sort of get your handle on a
code base you can click around this and
see where different objects are coming
from that being said it might not help
you understand why a memory leak
happened what is holding on to my memory
well if you want to get that information
you have to go over here to this icon
this is the heaped-up icon and and click
the heap dump so what I'm actually going
to do here just to let you know when I I
could not find a leaking activity or
fragment in the Santa tracker app so
full disclosure I added one and what I
did is I added a memory leak to this
penguin swim game here so actually let's
go ahead and go into the app now the
activity and leave it and let me
actually do another heap dump all right
so we're about to get a bunch of heap
dump information here so I know that the
fragment inside this activity is called
swim fragment so just like CPU we have
the filter button here and I can I can
filter out all of the different objects
and find that yep sure enough this
swimming fragment activity fragment is
still alive and I'll click on it I'll
select the active instance there is a
lot going on here so I'm gonna take a
moment to sort of explain a little bit
and let's just take a step back and and
and take a moment to absorb it so I
really want to explain what this depth
idea is so imagine all your Java memory
that can be cleaned up by the garbage
collector collector lives in this heap
there are some special Java objects that
live outside of this circle those are
called GC roots when you create a new
thread that basically creates this
special GC root or static variables are
an instance of a GC root so what ends up
happening is you might in a thread
create an instance of some class that it
in turn creates an instance of another
class and it in turn so on and so forth
and so basically what you're doing is
you're creating this long chain of
objects and each item in that chain has
a further
their depth from the GC root now you may
have heard that cycles are not a problem
to the garbage collector I can point at
you and then you point at you and you
point back at me but if we can't all be
reached that'll all get removed by the
garbage collector so one of the things
to note is when you take a heap dump you
might see a scary amount of things
holding on to Mike on my instance but a
lot of those are harmless a lot of them
are potentially just cycles and one way
that you can kind of know it's not
always true but it's a good heuristic is
if there the depth is greater than your
own depth so let me explain why that is
so imagine that the garbage collection
route points to you you create a child
instance and one of the things you do is
you give it your this pointer so it's
pointing back at you that's a very
common thing here you point back at me
you're my child but you know who your
parent is so that means my depth is then
going to be added on to that this
pointers debt so that's the reason that
some of these depths here may indicate
that even though you're seeing that it's
not an issue
you'll also notice here that there's a
few of these items in the depth column
where the depth is blank that means that
there's actually no way to reach these
at the moment from the garbage collect
from any garbage collection route so it
will eventually be cleaned up even
though it's showing up in the heap dump
right now you don't have to worry about
it just ignore it it's as good as
reclaimed just to make sure we
understand this a little bit with a
concrete example I'm actually going to
look here at this code which is not the
cause of our memory leak our depth is
one this this items depth is two so what
this is saying is somewhere there's an
instance of a score view class and that
score view class has a variable called
share click listener whose value is me
so let's go ahead and take a look at
swimming fragment and I'm gonna search
for get score of you so before when I
saw this I was trying to look through
the code I said there's got to be some
way that I'm gonna get a score of you
that points at me and there's this get
score view method inside my swimming
fragment if I jump to it what you're
gonna see is yep we create one and we
pass into this pointer
so that's sort of explaining why there
is a cycle there I don't have to worry
about it but at least today sort of
explains why it's showing up in the heap
dump now you're also noticed that's
there's a lot of this dollar signs zero
symbols what's going on here because
you're gonna see it a lot you all know
what that this pointer is but you if you
are an inner class if you're a nested
class and you need to have access to
your outer classes fields the way that
it works is the compiler generates a
synthetic variable and instead of
calling it this because that's taken it
calls it this dollar signs here so this
dollar sign zero means the this that's
one level out of my scope and anytime
you create an inner class that has a
reference to its outer class or you
create a closure an anonymous class
instance it's gonna have that so you
know if you're all using lambdas in your
code or anonymous classes you're gonna
see a lot of these dist:0 m is it's a GC
root it makes it really suspicious so
let's jump to the source right now
hopefully you know I might look at this
and say oh I wrote this long-running
task as you can see it's not a static
class it's a final class so if it's not
static it's gonna hold on to a reference
to the parent class that's what's going
on here and I might say oh this
long-running task I created it but I
forgot to cancel it so let's go ahead
and take a look here
yeah sure enough I left it commented out
for no good reason let me uncomment it
there and let's relaunch so what we're
gonna do now is let me just make sure
it's saved there we go what we're gonna
do now is reboot it just to make sure
that in fact this swimming fragment was
released one of the things to keep an
eye out for when you're hunting for
memory leaks is static variables or
singleton classes that are holding on to
your class or registering yourself with
a listener but forgetting to remove it
or any of these inner classes that for
some reason may not end up you know
stopping and they're still running even
though the activity is trying to exit
are we profiling here yes we are still
going and then another thing I want to
mention is it's not always gonna be this
you're not always gonna have this
obvious culprit so in that case what
you're gonna want to do is you know I
would say just try to get to know the
code look for those things that I talked
about let's go ahead and enter and well
I get here while I talk and you know if
you've cleaned it up even if you didn't
find it through the heap dump the heap
dump is still gonna be the source of
truth it's still going to be the thing
that guarantees to you that your
memories actually reclaimed so I'm gonna
go ahead here go back into the memory
profiler I'm gonna click on the garbage
collector so you may have noticed these
garbage collected events automatically
at the bottom so for example there's a
lot there that's when the garbage
collector decided to collect on its own
but you can also click the garbage
collection button to manually cause it
to to to get run now we still see
swimming fragment here let's see if the
depth is actually so as you can see
swimming fragment is still showing up
which is I could be nervous what
happened but the depth column here is
blank
everything is just basically getting is
waiting to be picked up by the garbage
collector you know you can press the
garbage collector a few more times one
trick I like to do is rotate the phone
and then rotate it again any time you
rotate an Android phone lots of fun
things happen it tells the garbage
collector things are going on so in that
case let's just do another heap dump
here and we'll see if the swimming
fragment is truly well and collected it
which just came with a drum roll and
there you go it's gone so the final
thing I want to quickly talk about is if
you're looking at the heap dump you're
not always necessarily hunting memory
leak you might not know some major class
to look out for so there's this concept
of shallow size and retain size so
shallow size is the size of a single
instance of some class that it's that's
been allocated and retained size is all
of the things that's holding on to so
what you may want to do is hunt sort
your shallow size for your retain size
maybe investigate to see if there's any
sort of suspicious memory things there
or maybe you clean up your design and
some memory there earlier anyway that
ends our demo and back to xiukong let's
go to the slides
ok cool so to recap in today's demo we
have shown to use CPU profiler and
memory profiler to get a better
understanding of the code base of the
center Center tracker app and to be
honest Dave and I don't know much about
it before we are preparing for this talk
and we also shown that we don't only use
profilers to diagnose performance issues
we also use the profilers to help us
understand the performance of this app
as we said before there are also Network
and energy providers in in your studio
but unfortunately we don't have time to
cover them today so please refer to our
online documents and talks to learn more
so we hope you have learned some tricks
and tips from our demo today we hope
they are useful when you approach your
own code base with NGO studio profilers
at your site thank you very much for
attending our talk
[Applause]
[Music]